one of the maladies of the modern age is
that even though collectively we have
more than we've ever dreamed possible
we remain perpetually dissatisfied it's
almost like we are wired never to be
content and it seems to be the case I
mean it's been written that we are
insatiable wanting machines designed to
desire and so in some ways that has made
us reach out and transcend boundaries we
didn't stay in the caves we haven't
stayed on the planet we went to the moon
we criss cross the skies we extend and
we transcend but on the other hand that
exploratory itch that genetic pull that
makes us tread forth always in search of
the insatiable deliciousness of the new
the wholly other the mysterium tremendum
fic know some of the unfamiliar also
makes quotidian day-to-day life kind of
banal again it's kind of sad because the
very same quality that makes us these
majestic creatures is soar above the
heavens and transcend their boundaries
has made us perpetually dissatisfied
neurotic beings living in urban centers
drowning and consumption and an over
capitalist bloated system that can no
longer satiate its always wanting
something else until we're like you know
overwhelmed and overweight and like you
know immobilized by how spoiled we've
become and yet we enjoy very little of
it so what we do
I don't we how do we find a way to
leverage and combine and reconfigure
this detention of this situation you
know that we always want more has made
us great but that we always want more
also makes us kind of miserable well and
so I don't know I haven't resolved that
yet I haven't resolved that yet
you